[Music]
indeed him of the future of the planet
under necessary shock to the system I am
human evolutionary change will it prove
superhuman Harry you bad guy mission has
been compromised
we need help our targets name is Brixton
he's a ghost we're gonna need the best
trackers in the business Luke Hobbs on
what you call a nice cold can of
whoop-ass career lawmen always get this
guy we're gonna need to operate outside
the system Deckard Shaw I'm what you
might call a champagne problem rogue
former mi6 agent doesn't play well with
others
if we stand a chance against Brixton all
you guys have to work together
this job requires stealth
look at ya I'm trying to save the world
which for the record would be my one
time cuz I'm really good at it you have
no idea what we're dealing with
Hobbs is sure
you know in a war
you've got one
remember me
[Music]
what
[Music]
three sharks will kill a man there we
are the back rest piece got big mouth
huh yeah I thought was cool things in
the moment
[Music]
you